For the first time in history, we have
professional conversation hvers. They're
called podcasters. And one of the most
overlooked social skills that make these
people successful is the ability to
connect with anyone, even if they have
nothing in common.
>> A lot of these authors and professors,
I've never spoken a word to them, nor
have I heard them speak.
>> So, in this video, I'm going to show you
six techniques that the best
conversationalists use and that you can
use today to connect with anyone and
start to have more meaningful
relationships. So, first, this is
something that will make people
immediately like you in conversation,
and it's probably something that you
don't always do, which is letting them
know that you are happy to be speaking
with them.
>> First of all, let me just tell you how
impressed I am with what you've done.
Very, very nice to meet you.
>> Incredible to meet you. I'm
>> a gigantic fan,
>> man. I appreciate that.
>> It's an honor to meet you, man. Um, I I
I'm always fascinated by people that are
at the top of something that's insanely
difficult, like chess. Letting people
know that you're happy to be with them
can be done in many different ways. You
can compliment their work or you can
tell them that you'd like to see more of
what it is that they do.
>> You want me to keep going?
>> Go ahead. You just get you got to do the
whole song.
>> But no matter how you show it, genuine
appreciation makes people invest more of
themselves into the interaction. And
while it sounds very simple, most people
mess this up. They think that showing
enthusiasm makes them look desperate or
like they're beneath someone. And
sometimes they may attempt to gain
respect by acting like they don't know
about someone or don't care like Howard
Stern did early in his career.
>> Meet this Sophia Vagara.
>> Is she here?
>> I believe she is.
>> Hey now.
>> And why is she here? Do you know?
>> Cuz she's hot.
>> Yeah, she's hot. That's why. Because
Gary came in and showed me a picture of
her and I went, "Well, [__] her. I want
to take a look."
>> Why did she want to come?
>> I have no idea.
>> She's very hot.
>> She must have a website or something.
What else do hot chicks have? And sure,
acting cool and uninterested might get
people to try and impress you, but it
will not help people open up to you
because people want to know that if they
share something that's embarrassing or
vulnerable that you're going to stick
with them. And the cool guy cannot be
expected to do that. But if you want to
take things deeper, you need the second
point, which is you have to navigate the
conversation towards something more
personal than just small talk. And we
all know that most conversations start
off with the usual stuff, weather, work,
news, sports. But what is cool is that
just about any of these more boring
topics can be moved to a deeper context
with one simple question.
>> What did it make you feel?
>> Like I knew nothing.
>> Now, of course, you don't have to say
this verbatim. Anything that navigates
conversation towards feelings,
motivations, or values can work.
>> Where do you think you would be if it
wasn't for this?
>> Now, in that clip, Joe was able to
change topics to find out about Jimmy's
motivation. And because of it, the
conversation moved in a more vulnerable
direction towards Jimmy struggling with
Crohn's disease.
>> I mean, a little bit of baseball. I I
got Crohn's when I was 15, so I like I
played baseball non-stop. Um, and then
when I got crowns, I lost like 50 lbs.
Like, that
>> Oh, Jesus Christ.
>> I know.
>> Now, another way to get to feelings is
to ask about people's most important
relationships. For instance, Theo was
one of the few people in recent years to
ask Donald Trump about the loss of his
brother.
>> Do you remember the last time that you
saw him or spent with him? My brother
went through a lot of stuff so that I
didn't have to go through it. And then I
get to see him and learn.
>> Is he okay now?
>> Yeah, he's doing great now. Yeah, he's
doing great now. But it's just it's like
Yeah, that's one of the blessings I
think of having an older brother.
>> I never had a glass of alcohol. Never
ever did I have a glass of alcohol
>> because of him. And I would say that if
I did drink, I could, you know,
conceivably be the type of personality
that would have
>> Yeah.
>> like you that would have a problem. So
lean into conversation topics about
people's feelings, the motivations
behind their decisions, and their most
important relationships. If you do this,
you will very likely create an
opportunity to connect over the real
stuff. And to be fair, people still
won't be so forthcoming with their
feelings, motivations, or values. And
that's why this third very simple tool
can be useful. It's called paring, and
it's simply repeating back the last few
words of what someone has just said. I
used to start the morning every morning
praying,
>> you know, God don't make me read.
>> God don't make you read.
>> Yeah. In school because I was I was
right.
>> You can use this with anyone early on in
conversation. When people are sharing
what they're studying or doing for work,
you can repeat their title or their
major back to them with a sort of
curious intent, and that will get them
to talk about what they're doing or why
they chose it in the first place. Now,
it might seem small, but it makes people
feel like what they're saying is
important. And when people realize that
you're not waiting for them to be done,
they naturally go on to share more about
themselves.
>> It it takes you to a place.
>> Oh my god. It tells a story. It takes
you to a place.
>> Yeah.
>> So, at this point in conversation,
you've successfully moved towards
feelings and motivations. And this takes
us to the fourth point. This one is a
bit more challenging for most people.
You have to realize that when people do
start to open up, they may share things
that they're not totally proud of. And
if that happens, you need to avoid
judging them. Instead, you can watch
what Howard Stern does here and actually
be an advocate for the things that his
guests are ashamed of, like he did with
actress Charlie Theren, who opened up to
Howard about how she felt after having
been harassed by a Hollywood producer
early in her career.
>> I was so angry with myself that I didn't
say something. You know, I was like, why
I'm not that kind of girl? Like, why did
I not
>> tell him to go himself? Like, it made me
so angry.
>> You know why? Because in the moment, if
you're a decent human being, even you
can't believe what's happening to you
>> and you feel like you should be polite.
>> Yeah.
>> It's weird. And then afterwards, you go,
"Why am I so polite?"
>> Exactly.
>> Why am I such a good boy or good girl?
>> The point here is that we're all usually
a bit more insecure, jealous, and
fearful than we might appear early in
conversation. We hide those parts of
ourselves because we think that it's
necessary to being liked. But in order
to connect deeply with someone, we need
to take off the masks that we use to fit
in. And saying things like, "How could
you have done that?" or "I would never"
suggests that that other person, they
need to keep that mask on. So, a much
better response here is to advocate for
their vulnerability. And that can also
be done by giving space in moments where
vulnerability enters the conversation.
I've done a whole video on this next
clip because I love it so much. But you
can get an idea of what that looks like
here where Theo Von is holding space for
Son Strickland as he opens up about
childhood trauma.
>> Like I remember when I stopped believing
in God, man. Like like I um Yeah, it's
crazy, dude.
>> We don't have to talk, man. I can just
sit here with you for a minute.
>> And sometimes you can pause and
acknowledge someone's courage here. Like
when Joe Rogan sat down with a combat
vet who talked in detail about his
wartime injuries and how it hurt him
physically and emotionally.
>> You know, for someone like you who truly
understands the consequences of war,
like the physical consequences in a way
that none of us will understand, you
know, it's it's very not just it's brave
of you to talk about this, but it's also
it's so so valuable so valuable for
everybody that that hasn't served to to
understand what it really is. So, thank
you for that. So in your own life,
before you simply react or give advice
in these situations where people get
vulnerable, remember you can pause, hold
space, and acknowledge their bravery
first. It goes a long way to fostering
connection. Now, until now, everything
we've covered has been about encouraging
others to open up to us and to connect
with us. But if you're committed to
having deeper interactions, you can't
wait on other people to be brave enough
to share. You need to go there first.
And that means you need to reveal your
own vulnerabilities and hard truths
about yourselves. Now, Theo is quite
special here. Despite being someone
who's made a career creating laughter
and projecting happiness, he's also
found the strength to show his
vulnerable side and reveal more personal
struggles from low self-esteem to
relationship wounds with his father. You
know, like I love my dad, but I've also
always been a little bit angry at him. I
was 16 when he passed away and he was
86. And other kids would make fun of
him, and then I kind of made fun of him.
I would make the excuse, well, he
shouldn't have had a kid when he was
that old. You know, what was he
thinking? Maybe I was afraid to get to
know him because I knew he was going to
pass away. You know, when we would walk
somewhere, I would walk kind of far
behind him or away from him, you know,
because he wasn't the way that I wanted
him to be, you know, and I could have
had more memories with him if I hadn't
judged my father so much. I wish
somebody had taught me to have more
pride in my family when I was young.
When we become vulnerable, we drop the
social mask that says, "I'm super high
status. I'm above pain and hardship."
And that inspires other people to do the
same, which in turn creates
opportunities for true heartfelt
connection.
>> Some guy came up to me this morning at
the cafe and said, "Hey man, I got 5
years sober, you know, and uh and you're
just so excited when you see how
somebody's life gets different or
better." And not that I have anything to
do with that. I don't feel like I do,
but just that he wants to share that
with me and that he feels okay sharing
it, you know? So when it seems like on
the surface you have nothing in common
with somebody, it might just be because
you are hiding the commonalities from
one another. And if you go there first,
you open yourself up, you might find
that they relate more to your
vulnerabilities than the things that you
thought would get them to like you on
the surface. So here is one small
challenge for you. Next time you're
talking to someone and something
embarrassing comes up that's adjacent to
something that you have lived through,
don't hide it. share it without trying
to get any specific reaction or
necessarily making a big story out of
it. When people see that you are
available to be honest about your own
mistakes without making excuses or
forcing a trauma dump, they will start
doing the same thing. It's almost
instant and your openness is giving them
permission to be real as well.
>> And by the way, I I I I really
appreciate you being so vulnerable cuz
people watching there seeing that allow
them to be vulnerable because you're a
role model of that. So, having watched
all of this, my recommendation is that
you take just one tip that has resonated
with you in this video and implement it
today. And if you're wanting to go
beyond that to level up your charisma in
the fastest way possible, you may also
want to check out our 30-day program,
Charisma University. It'll give you the
specific daily actions to take so that
your confidence and your social skills
get a huge upgrade with most people
seeing results in just a few days. And
here are just what some of those results
have been. I don't even have a bachelor
diploma yet they want me to fill this
position and when I asked why this was
the answer. You have great social skills
which is rare for an engineer. You can
think quickly on your feet and you are
open and self assured in your demeanor.
Thank you so much for all that you have
taught me. You have truly changed my
life because without Charisma
University, I wouldn't have qualified
for that position in a million
lifetimes. Or check out this student's
experience with dating. Loving the
course. I've liked a girl for over a
year now, but never thought much of it
because I thought she was just too
pretty. Took your lessons, gave things a
shot, and now we are dating. And try
this one out for friendship. It has been
truly incredible. I have instantly had
results that seem insane. So many more
meaningful conversations. My friendships
have improved and my interactions with
total strangers are a new, exciting,
fulfilling thing. I want to recommend
this to everyone. This should be in our
basic education system. Now, the course
comes with a full money back guarantee,
so there is no risk to you trying. There
are thousands of people that have
improved their lives with Charisma
University, and I would love for you to
do the same. Either way, I hope that
this video has helped you and I look
forward to seeing you in the next